number four from the daily wire it says
actress and abortion activist bizzy
phillips
has revealed that her 12 year old child
is gay and uses they
them pronouns speaking on episode of her
podcast busy phillips is doing her best
that's the name of the podcast
she said that her child birdie came out
as gay uh she said quote
for those of you who are my friends
listening at home this is the first
you're hearing that birdie is gay and
out
birdie told us at 10 years old and we
immediately uh
we immediately knew we knew that birdie
knew
so let's go to a clip from the podcast
now here here she is busy phillips
recounting a conversation with her 12
year old daughter
who she saddled with the name birdie
which was really just the first of many
abuses it turns out
listen to this bird said um i said
you know bird i've been doing a bad job
with the pronouns
because birdie said that
they would like their pronouns to be
they them
and i haven't been doing it and i said
because
like i have this um
public persona and i want birdie to be
in control
of their own narrative and not have to
answer to anybody outside
of our friends and family if they don't
want to
and then byrd was like
i don't give a [ __ ]
like i would i you can
talk about that i'm gay and out you can
talk about my pronouns
i that would be cool with me that's
great
so i said okay
i'm just i'll i can talk about on the
podcast
and bernie was like and birdie was like
yeah talk about podcast mom like
okay throw my phone on the ground sorry
anyway so um
yeah it's been wild so birdie
my out kid
prefers they them i [ __ ] up sometimes
but we're i'm
trying my best yeah i i wish this was
similar to the camaro harris situation
and i could say that this is an invented
conversation that you had with her 12
year old
or 12 year old daughter um
but i don't think it is i think that
unfortunately that conversation really
happened
where 12 year old daughter was telling
her pronouns
and then when busy phillips asked
whether she could
reveal this on the podcast the ch the 12
year old daughter responded
i don't give an f i think
that's a real conversation because
that's the kind of mother that busy
phillips is now
it shouldn't surprise us as was noted
she's an abortion activist and uh
she's bragged in the past about getting
abortions so
this this is how she sees her children
she sees her children as unfortunately
many parents especially on the left do
in a dehumanized way you know she sees
her child
as either trash that can be discarded
like the one that she killed
or as political prop uh or even not a
political just a prop
something to be shown around
um an accessory maybe is a better word
for it
and that's what she's doing here kind of
like locking her daughter in
to this identity by announcing it
publicly
there's there's there's no good reason
there's no good loving
parenting sort of reason to take your
child's
confusion and they're working through it
and and you just broadcast it to the
entire world
that's not going to help you i mean even
even for a moment just
putting aside everything else and and um
pretending that it could be legitimate
for a 12 year old to identify
as they them or it could be legitimate
for anyone to identify as they them
which of course it isn't
because it doesn't mean anything but
putting that aside
just there's no reason to tell the world
about it there's no reason to publicize
it
she's 12 years old for god's sake
how will it benefit her for the whole
world to know about this
and busy philip says well i asked her i
asked her and she said she doesn't give
an f
so i did it yeah once again
this is the theme we see so often
especially with
with uh with with parents who have
children who are gender confused
so often what we see are the parents
looking to the children for guidance
the parents saying to the kids you show
me the way you you
you tell me what i'm supposed to do here
i'll let you
take the lead no no that's not what you
say to your 12 year old you
that's not what you say to your 12 year
old your 12 year old needs
you to be the adult your 12 year old
needs you to be the rational one
your 12 year old needs you to be the one
who can see beyond
the nose on your face who can think in
the long term
kids can't do that that's the point
psychologically they don't they don't
have the capacity
yet for things like long-term planning
they can't do that at 12 they can't even
they can't do it at 16.
they certainly can't do it at seven or
eight or whatever their age now where
kids are just quote unquote deciding
they want to transition
they can't do they they don't have the
psychological neurological capacity for
it
you do or you're supposed to as an adult
so you're supposed to be the one who
says
listen no i'm not going to put this out
there for the whole world we're going to
keep this between us private
and also you know you're obviously
confused you're working through some
things
let me help you out we'll take you to
counseling let's try
let's try to figure out what's really
going on here you're
you're a girl it's wonderful that you're
a girl but you don't want to
identify as a girl there's obviously
something happening here
so let's figure it out you take the
child to counseling you help them
if your child comes to you and says i'm
they them
that is your child saying i am confused
i don't understand i don't know who i am
and i don't know who i am because you
the parent have failed
it's your job to help me figure out who
i am
to help me figure out if i'm a girl what
it means to be a girl in the world
you're the mother that's what you're
supposed to be doing
that's what your child is really saying
to you only they're not saying exactly
that
audibly because they don't have the
capacity to say it they don't understand
their own feelings this kind of thing
will never
fail to just infuriate me
especially as a parent i don't think you
need to be a parent to be disgusted and
infuriated by this kind of madness but
as a parent i just i
i have kids myself and the idea
of me turning to them for guidance
or the idea that they would make some
mostly incoherent declaration about
their own identity and i would just take
it
seriously and assume
that it's that it's meaningful and just
go with it
it's mind-boggling to me they're kids
i'm the adult that's the way the
relationship is supposed to work
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content